Speaker 1: Many things to talk about in this
first portion of today's Friday show, first,
I want to follow up on a story from earlier
this week.
Earlier this week, we talked about a former
Fox News host, Bill O'Reilly, absolutely losing
it at an airport, treating JetBlue employees
terribly because their flight to Turks and
Caicos was running very, very late.
Well, the man who supports the party of personal
responsibility and supports taking responsibility
and holding people accountable for their actions,
he says.
Really, this is Biden's problem, and it's
because of Biden that he flipped out on a
on a worker at the airport.
As a reminder, let's start with the original
clip.
This is Bill O'Reilly at JetBlue in JFK Airport,
threatening to get a worker fired and demanding
his name and aggressively leaning towards
the guy and all of that.
Speaker 2: This isn't Bill O'Reilly.
You got into contact with.
Bill O'Reilly on the outside.
Unidentified: I wanted to be a manager.
Speaker 2: All three hours we have.
Speaker 1: Listen, flight delays suck, it's
not the gate agents fault, like I said, you
don't treat people like this, and now he starts
with the threatening for losing your job and
Unidentified: you're going to find out.
You look at.
When you start your brand new violence, you
want to know what it's like here.
You're going to lose your job.
Speaker 1: You're going to lose your job,
so anyway, that was the incident, and now
we have an explanation from Bill O'Reilly
and he's blaming Biden.
I don't know, guys.
Maybe there's something to it.
Bill O'Reilly says it's Biden's fault.
He threw a fit, and the statement is.
On Tuesday, O'Reilly tweeted the character
Assassins on social media are completely lying
about my interaction with the JetBlue guy
who misled passengers during a five hour delay.
I expected this.
Speaking to media aide, O'Reilly acknowledged
that he handled the situation poorly and could
have used different words, but refused to
apologize.
He claimed numerous people recognized him,
and they started asking him about the hold
up.
He almost became like a union rep, guys, or
Bill O'Reilly was just speaking for the people.
That's what was going on.
He insisted the heat on him is a distraction
from the real story, which is that JetBlue
is subpar.
The story is JetBlue can't get their flights
off the ground.
It was crazy in the terminal.
For some reason.
The Biden administration is not big on solving
problems, and this is a huge problem.
How this has to do with Joe Biden, I truly
have no idea.
And the story here?
Remember, there's two stories here.
One story is they say they're all about personal
responsibility when they do something, when
they choose to behave a certain way and it's
horrible and they get called out.
They blame somebody else.
And of course, secondly, it's they always
insist in political discussions.
You must state your principles.
Give me your list of principles here.
And one of the principles is personal responsibility.
As soon as the principles are inconvenient,
they ignore the principles, they abandon the
principles, and that's the way it works.
And as I said before, and I'll say it again,
I have been so frustrated.
Some of the most frustrating situations I
can remember relate to airlines.
Once my flight was just canceled, there was
no reason why.
But so is there a technical problem?
No.
Is there a weather problem?
The flight has been canceled.
Never an explanation.
I lost today, but there were rebooking you
tomorrow.
You want to start screaming at people, but
you don't because you realize it's not this
person's fault.
And my guess when O'Reilly says that they
were being misled?
I know that feeling.
It's very common when you fly that they say,
folks.
We have just does the light on that's on the
plane and we want maintenance to look at it.
It's just going to be 10 minutes until they
get here.
So we're going to hold off on boarding for
now.
OK.
Well, ten minutes go by and they say we're
we're still waiting for maintenance.
And finally, maintenance gets there.
But they said it was 10 minutes for maintenance
to get there.
They didn't say anything else.
Their maintenance has identified a problem
and we're going to look for a part here.
And if we get it, it's only about an hour
fix once we find the part.
OK, 45 minutes go by.
We've not been able to find the part.
It is in our fix once we find the part.
But this actually happened to me in Las Vegas,
they said.
The closest part right now is in San Diego.
We found the part and it's only an hour to
install it, but it's coming in out a San Diego
flight.
That flight leaves San Diego in a half hour.
Very short flight.
Now you're doing math, you're going, OK, wait.
So we're already 75 minutes delayed.
The flight doesn't leave for 45, then it takes
45, and then you got to get the part and then
it's another hour and then and then you get
to it now.
Fortunately, this didn't happen to me, but
then the classic is our crew has timed out.
They now are mandated to rest, which I have
no problem.
We want everybody to be rested.
I don't want unrests, crew and pilots flying.
And then you lose a day.
I mean, listen, I get it.
These things are frustrating.
You don't start treating people like crap.
That's really the principle we should all
be sticking to.
Bill O'Reilly blaming everybody but himself.